take my heart when you go kick tsuya
Westworld season 2 episode 8 Wow just
yeah Wow
so I part of me wants to wait and do
this tomorrow except I don't know that I
will have time to do it tomorrow just
because I almost kind of want a night to
sort of go over all this in my head this
was a really impressive episode and not
there have been a number of really
impressive Westworld episodes but
Westworld in sort of typical Nolan flat
and Nolan fashion is a more cerebral
than it is emotional as a general rule
so when episodes of Westworld are really
good they're really good cerebrally
they're really good on an intellectual
level this thing is that but is also
really emotional and a lot of that comes
down to the performance of the lead in
this episode zan McLaren who I know from
the second season of Fargo where he
played Hansie so this was an actor I
already knew and I who I knew was good
but this was a whole range of stuff on
him that really it takes you on a
journey on an emotional journey through
his eyes and I love the ways in which
his sort of coming to self was almost
the opposite of Maeve because Maeve
started to come to a level of
self-awareness seeing the repetitions in
her deaths actually and you know living
and dying so many times whereas he went
almost 10 years without dying and which
actually was a really cool note a really
cool insight that we got with that with
those technicians going we only update
with them when they die it shows you how
little regard there is for the host like
oh you know well we'll deal
when they died they all died it doesn't
take long so the idea of one going nine
years without dying just kind of throws
everything out of whack just on that
level but he he gives such an amazing
performance through this and I I needed
that I've said for the past couple
episodes that I really they need to
drill in on these ghost nation
characters or at least one of them and I
need to know what their deal is and I'd
now I feel that I do and it's not just
that somebody sat down and explained to
me what their deal is I went on this
journey with him and I get exactly where
he's coming from and that is just really
really impressive
and as much as this is practically a
one-man show there are a lot of other
really good performances in it as well
the the woman who plays his love she has
this one moment that was an astounding
bit of acting to me when he has taken
her and she didn't she didn't recognize
him initially and he just you know
calmly approaches her and he says you
know the phrase that they would say to
each other and this look on her face of
Revelation and then of sadness this this
like flooding over her of what she's
lost and what's been missing for who
knows how long that was a lot to
communicate in probably like five
seconds of just you know facial response
not even a line and she did it she sold
it
um we get a little bit of maybe I have I
have a feeling that the the fact that
Tessa Thompson's character last name
Hale and I've lost her first name here
but um Charlotte I just had that
whispered to me off screen you might
have even heard that thank you thank you
sweetie
so Charlotte Charlotte Hales name being
heard by Maeve I
expecting that to come back I'm
expecting that to bite them in the ass
very very hard and also with with me we
have the writer character and I've
really I've said this a couple of
reviews before this I've really come to
appreciate him as a character and you
can see the depth of when he's when he's
being sorry to you know saying I'm sorry
and you know you can see the grief on
his face it's more than just her that I
get from what he say he's not just
saying I'm sorry to her he say he's
sorry to every host he ever wrote a
horrible violent tragic story for them
to play out for his or other people's
entertainment I I feel the weight of
that on him there it is worth saying
though that they've kind of given the
bad emotional through-line
to him that was kind of inhabited by
Felix last season and Felix didn't even
show up this episode and they better
find out something to do with him in the
last two episodes because right now he
gets filed under why did why did you
even come back this season he's
literally been nothing done with you so
that and I'm not saying that him taking
on you know is sort of a more progressed
version of Felix's emotional
through-line it was a bad thing okay I
think we actually get more depth with
him because he had further to come
whereas Felix seemed to have a certain
amount of sympathy for the hosts even
before we met him some other things that
that were really cool I the little bit
we get a Ford in this I felt like I got
a lot of insight into not just Ford's
state of mind but his approach to the
hosts and and sort of his his feelings
and his thoughts on how they were
changing and evolving and this was
something actually my partner Liz and I
talked through and I don't know if this
is the way this will play out in the
show but
but it feels like to me at this point is
that Arnold
recognized way before Ford the evolution
and the possibility of sentient that
existed within the hosts but his mistake
was to try and force that evolution
forward with what he did to Dolores to
feeding in you know the Wyatt angle to
triggering her killing him that wasn't a
natural evolution he tried to push them
forward to where he believed they were
going to end up being Ford on the other
hand took a lot longer to realize what
Arnold always knew but and possibly just
by default for how long he you know he
hadn't been aware of this but he seems
to be allowing them to come to their own
natural evolution and I actually think
that might be why you know the this
character that we really get to dig into
and this episode along with Maeve seemed
to be way more stable than Dolores who
had you know the the furthest point of
her evolution thrust upon her and and
you know the sort of everything going on
in her head doesn't seem to be all
clicking right yet whereas these other
characters that we're seeing they
arrived at a natural progression and
evolution and awareness and and they
seem to be much more sane for a lack of
a better term than Dolores does and I
really have to wonder if that's if
that's the reason well I'm not even
gonna wonder at this point I'm gonna
choose to believe that's the reason
until proven otherwise open to the
possibility that I may be proven wrong
on that oh boy what else have we got
there were a fair number of predictions
in the comments section
the last review of this I did as to how
ed Harris the man in black was gonna
survive most of them centered around the
I forget what it was called but it was
sort of a tissue Bhandar thing that that
they thought was what he had gotten out
of that hole in the wall the literal
hole in the wall when he first hooked up
with Lawrence I didn't catch that at the
time but I thought that was a good call
other people said it was gonna be his
daughter who it kinda was nobody called
the ghost nation saving him
that I didn't call that one and I'm
really enjoying his daughter and the
disdain she's she seems to hold him in
and I'd like I love her line you know
he's a burden only I can bear I I think
just that she would even say that says
everything about her relationship and
her feelings about this man so I am
curious and hopeful to dig into that a
bit more which it really was looking
like the next episode is gonna do so I'm
looking forward to that Maeve's daughter
is there as well as she doesn't oh I
almost said she doesn't do much except
that she has to exude a real sense of
just being present when when she's
listening to the story that's being told
to her and actually that's not nothing
that can be very difficult to do and a
lot of actors especially young actors
aren't good at it aren't good at being
you know being there with no lines and
just being present and she was and that
helped elevate an already great story
that we were getting and then visually
this episode's gorgeous also there were
shots here that just about took my
breath away but really at the end of it
it is the emotional through line of this
characters journey because I'm not gonna
lie I did choke up I didn't full-on cry
but I did choke up at a few points in
this you know as as his as he began to
realize what he had lost
like especially when he's down in the
cold storage and he says you know my
pain had been selfish because everyone
down there someone else was Mourning
even if they didn't know why and his
appreciation for the depth of the pain
that existed and I'll just mention this
because I had mentioned might have even
been last step in last review I did it
was the last couple reviews at least
that I appreciated how little nudity
there was this season and we got quite a
bit more of it but I'm okay with that
because it was it was in the cold
storage and it was in terms of these the
hosts being objects being props being
mannequins in this moment bringing back
the dehumanization which was why the
nudity was or at least for me was more
or less acceptable in the first season
because that that dehumanization was
such an important theme of that and that
realization of that was really important
to this characters journey so you know
him going to the cold storages seeing
all that was important and it did matter
and it did I think it did actually
enhance the moment for him to see all
these bodies stripped down to nothing
just standing there just being stored
because they don't they're not needed
right now and this was just this was a a
beautiful episode a powerful episode an
emotional episode this my know I think I
can safely say this is my favorite
episode of this particular season I'd
have to I'd have to think harder on
whether or not it tops anything from
season one
it might I'm not gonna make that claim
right now though but that'll do it
that'll do it for this one kicks Ouya
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's stuff to do you
know all the stuff like and subscribe
and check out my podcast and Scourby on
patreon perhaps and Twitter and t-shirts
and
there's more stuff even beyond that all
of which is listed down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]